steve austin former pro wrestler Stone
Cold Steve Austin and has a new show
it's on the USA Network straight-up
Steve Austin you can catch every Monday
at 11:00 Eastern on USA Network it's
good to see you good to see you too it's
been a while
was there any bad blood between us when
we did that ESPN commercial 15 years ago
like you you told me to hit you in the
back with the folding chair twice and I
had a couple of takes and I hit you as
hard as I possibly could no bad blood
we're good absolutely remember I told
you I said hey man you gotta lay it in
because it's got to look good because if
you hit me easy and soft it's gonna kill
the whole thing so you had to lay it in
and then you also said hit me twice
it'll be a bet like you're the one that
said to the guys who were making the
ESPN promo it'll be funnier if I ask him
to hit me again yeah gonna get one more
of those and I remember yeah and it's
funny because it's really one of the
first sets
I'd been on and I guess I didn't know
protocol and so you kind of want that to
be the directors idea so when he I ran
it by him and it's kind of maybe
offended him a little bit and then all
of a sudden when it became his idea he
was cool with it and then you therefore
hit me twice can we play that and if you
listen to the audio you're gonna be able
to hear and hopefully we're able to play
this and there's audio attached to this
hey stone cold well you don't up so late
hey dad just studying I'm fading pretty
fast I know just the thing
[Music]
can I get one more of those sure thanks
buddy that helps you were you were great
you were your comedic timing is awesome
there I thought that really showed my
range is an actor now I have a little
pad that you had in the middle of your
back little turtle shell now is that
what you normally wear in a situation
like that when you're in the ring well
no because I just want a pair of trumps
and boots okay so if I hit you with a
chair in the ring I'm hitting you you've
been hit with him oh yeah million of
them you know and basically what you
want to do when you're giving a guy
chair shots you want to line up
perpendicular so if the guy's gonna say
hands and knees this way you want to hit
him perpendicular to his back do you
want Paulie to come over here and be
down on the ground you can tell me what
he does I mean okay Paulie come on over
and and then Steve will show us how did
I get up here so he's here yeah I can be
here and I can hit him but if I start
swinging the thing this this lip could
end up hitting him in the back yeah okay
that's not good that's gonna open him up
you come here perpendicular right yeah
you're using angles learn to stuff in
school like Michael right like so like
you bring that thing I mean you're
bringing it from way back because it's a
visual yes and then you're you're he
gets pounded and you're trying to go
once you lay that chair in you're trying
to back off a little bit you don't want
to swing through you know like you got
to trying to add a baseball something
like yeah so you kind of want to pull it
but man he's gonna feel a lot of impact
it's gonna hurt so I can be laying these
things in on him when you see a guy go
belly up
that means no mas I've had too much Oh
yeah because he now look what he's
giving me you get four arms exposed and
knees and stuff like that and so you
that's when you don't swing another
chair unless you know that I'm gonna go
to this oh and go like solar plexus and
midsection like the guillotine yeah
you're gonna stab and I did that to the
rock in 17 when I when I turned heel but
after I land bash didn't with a bunch of
back shots
I might seize my time and you're good
pause they don't teach you this in
professional wrestling school you can
it's kind of like on-the-job training so
when you turned heel you know cuz I know
that you know your audience like you're
portrayed a certain way but when you
become the bad guy how does how does
your fan base react to that well they
they revolted I mean they didn't want to
hate me by that time they loved me so
much you know we you always want to do
something big at WrestleMania I don't
think we had anything big that year so I
told Vince hey man I'll turn hill he
goes okay because you know at a certain
point you just kind of flip and you
think things gonna get hotter but it has
to be warranted so there's really
nothing but I was feeling flat kind of
going into WrestleMania 17 because I'd
been hot for so long and I've always
liked to be the bad guy anyway so that's
why I wanted to turn bad guys so I'd
have fun but people didn't like it what
did the rock say about it rock was cool
with it rock was about to ride off in
the sunset and go film I think might
have been his first movie and now he's
the biggest movie star in the world it
amazing oh it's incredible
the amount of work that that guy's done
and you know to have the division in the
future and it dream to get in acting and
now he's he's crushing he's everywhere
are you gonna get rock on your show I
would love to have him on the show and
the people were asking me if I could
have a dream guest and I don't like to
name names because we've had a lot of
people that we reached out to in the
first season but we couldn't get just
because of scheduling but yeah he's a
guy because of our background you know I
don't email him we don't text each other
I don't even have his phone number
but as soon as we get in a room together
you know it's that instant camaraderie
friendship but I'd love to spend some
time with him because I always brought
out the best in him and he always
brought out the best in me could you
take him at your peak in his his peak a
real fight use that well I was
I'm gonna say yes that I could because I
believe in myself but rocks a big tough
guy and played football at Miami so he
was the last guy you want to see do what
who's the last guy you want to see in
front of you like a man you'll fight Oh
Haku you know everybody knows that Haku
was the baddest guy that there ever was
as far as fighting real fighting in the
business because that guy he just had
these crazy you know large hands I got a
pretty good set of mitts
but man he's gonna be pulling your eyes
out he's gonna be biting me I mean when
you mess with him you're really you're
flirting with death who's the greatest
performer you've ever seen man you know
Hulk Hogan really knew how to work a
crowd and format relationship with that
crowd but Nature Boy Ric Flair
who I considered to be the greatest of
all time he brought and looking a little
bit more show business into it when he'd
start falling over and after after
taking a bunch of punches and traveling
the world like he did back in the day
we've always known that the business has
been at work but at the elite level
traveling around the world and truly
defending the World Championship Ric
Flair's the goat and you start to you
know you start to formulate your
personality because I don't know if your
you're actually able to be yourself or
they tell you to be somebody how did it
work with you where they said okay they
this is who you are or you said this is
who I am you know you kind of going out
there and you're learning and you're
learning who you want to be and I
emulated Ric Flair when I first started
out and when I was stunning Steve back
in Georgia and everybody because of my
ability back then at the mechanic stage
hey man this this guy right here is
gonna be the next Ric Flair well man
there's never gonna be the next Ric
Flair so I was more of a technical
wrestler back in the day and then in 97
when I got dropped on my head and almost
got paralyzed bruised my spinal cord
I had to modify my style and not be so
technical and turned more into a brawler
and that's when I came up with the Stone
Cold Steve Austin thing and with the
modified style the the gimmick or the
name that I grew in
which is basically you cover sports so I
played you know football baseball track
all of that when I played football and I
was a linebacker defensive end I was a
running back I wasn't fast enough to run
around anybody so I ran over people but
I have but I have a killer instinct you
know I'm going for the win at all times
and so when I found that part of me in
professional wrestling even though the
business is at work when I just turned
myself up to 11 that's who I am and
that's when everything started to work
for me but everything was to work in
progress and like we were talking off
the air and his first season of straight
up Steve Austin you know trying to find
myself you know as that person
interviewing people and getting to know
them when did you know you were famous
that grew is there a moment that you
said my life just changed
I started feeling it one night in
Chicago at the Rosemont horizon and
that's where my favorite buildings to
work Andy favorite because it's wood
ceiling and the acoustics are so good in
there and Chicago crowd is so crazy and
anytime you do something I mean you're
listening to that crowd and if you're
not listening that crowd you're doing it
wrong because everything you do you do
to elicit a response based on that
response you you respond accordingly and
man when you at the gas pedal in that
building and they give you that feedback
you know exactly where you're going so
it was one night we were in a tag match
and I started really feeling the energy
from that crowd responding to everything
I did I said hey man this is coming on
and to answer your your your famous
question I never even really considered
that you know I never never never
thought about it but did you guys yeah
women like crazy your guys are out there
basically naked performing your
performers your stars your worldwide
like they camping out at hotels waiting
for you how crazy did it get when you
were single well I've been married four
times
[Laughter]
my current wife my wife now it was my
soulmate I've been with her 15 years
we've been married nine so I'm glad I
found her when I found her but what was
it like before that again it's like II
Maggie I heard you talking about goth I
read you all the sports you talked about
it's everywhere you know you know what I
mean yeah whatever lonely no no and I'm
a loner now would be because you're
going into a different City you're like
a band yes like you guys are you're rock
stars you're a lot of times you know you
might be I don't know if you considered
famous but you're on television so you
have exposure right but you know most
time you know before you make it big I
mean you got three four or five guys
crammed in a rental car so you can all
split gas you got three or four guys in
a hotel room splitting beds low guy on
the totem pole or the guy with the
least-experienced is sleeping on the
floor and you know so you have exposure
but you're not really famous and then
you know I guess it looks glorious on TV
but the lifestyle in and of itself is
kind of like you know just caveman
Express it was a great life but yeah I
think Ric Flair I always looked at like
this way you live three lives in one
body on one hand you're professional
athlete because you train like one and
you work like one in the ring other hand
you're rock star because when you go
someplace you know if you want anything
it's there and you can have it you know
with respect about anything and on the
other hand you're like a truck driver
because you know these days guys are
doing tour buses and stuff like that but
you know you take the flights you get
your rental car and you're driving all
over the United States so it's all those
things going on and a lot of guys and
you know met an early demise because
they get there they got caught up in it
I look forward to seeing the next
episode it's straight-up Steve Austin
you can catch it every Monday at 11:00
Eastern on USA Network Baker Mayfield
Dale jr.
Becky Lynch from WWE Rob Riggle on there
so pretty good guest list there what's
the biggest challenge that you're
finding as the host man you know I've
been podcasting for about six years I
think that's helped me really listening
you know that's the key you know really
listening and you know you tried really
finding myself who and what I am you
know in the show this is Season one we
filmed that pilot about a year ago and
you know filming a pilot I mean you have
this concept and this idea but when you
go out there you know I don't really
know what I'm doing yet my guests didn't
really know what what he's doing out
there and you're like throwing stuff on
the wall and seeing what sticks maybe
you're in a tank running over a car in
one episode hey man that's right up my
alley you know when you get that wake-up
drink a couple cups of coffee
my wife says what are you doing today I
said I know we're crushing cars in a
tank so you know it was good but when
you're doing something and you have an
activity to bond over you know you're
trying to walk and chew bubble gum at
the same time and some of the stuff is
even new to me but you just you you own
it you go out there you try to form some
chemistry and a relationship with your
guests and have a great conversation and
you want them to shine obviously because
they're the guests but there's a lot of
moving parts and it's a whole lot
different from my podcast obviously
because I'm in my studio next door to my
house one on one with one person and
nobody's there all of a sudden you got a
crew of 85 and I've got to thank USA
Network first and foremost for the
opportunity but the crew that they hired
to support me was probably the best crew
that could have hired so I got a I got a
lot of great help I wish you well with
it it's great to see again once again I
get more comments they actually took
that commercial off the air not long
after we did it they were worried about
kids trying to emulate that not knowing
that you had this little pad in the
middle of your back yeah and they were
worried about that cuz we were
professionals we were professionals and
I trusted you I know you know what when
you see the papers flying like you can
hear the wind of that chair I want to
hit you so hard and I had you were a
nice guy no you know I had no problem
with you and we have similar builds and
I thought you know what I'm just gonna
whale
on him and then when you said give me
another one I said I'm gonna give you
another one and I gave you everything I
had yeah and you know if you to raise
that chair up about six that you might
have clipped me riding back to the head
like I was just demonstrating so
probably when you go out there and
you're doing something like that first
of all never hit anybody what's still
chair kids out there put the chair down
but you know what I'm saying is man when
you're laying that chair and somebody
you've got to bring it or you're gonna
kill the angle but but that person is
trusting you to take care of them and
vice versa so there's a lot that goes
into that but it can be very dangerous
now it's great to see a good luck with
the show and if you're watching on
DirecTV audience Network channel 239 or
B or live.com during the commercial
break we're gonna have a gun show
between Stone Cold Steve Austin and
fritzy fritzy just does tries and buys I
haven't worked out a couple of days I've
been kind of busy so you might want to
do a party pump there it's called
working out try it you should try it's
Monday nights with Stone Cold Steve
Austin on USA Network straight-up Steve
Austin right so we noticed your arms and
then princey takes great pride in his
arms as well and I don't know the last
time you had a pose on Seton you're
probably not the right guy that's where
we should not be seen him we should not
be did you ever look like that maybe
maybe you're like 9 years okay fritzy
they want to come out and do the pose
off we still
yeah yeah let's get out of the way okay
look he's already been pumped oh yeah
who's gonna have oil on I haven't
touched a weight in a week then I got on
a high our Giants what do you think of
those are your sir yours are a little
bigger right yeah
he skipped and I heard that you only try
norms but I don't do like when weight or
so lot else in it back a few years also
this is another really happy saving yeah
he does that for everybody oh you're
gonna go just a double by yeah okay okay
and and a no I've ever fleshed I mean
I'm ideal you know you want to be in
shape but I was basically from a
football background so I was never
considered a body guy I was a wrestler
so the guys you know like Ultimate
Warrior those were those are body guys
they depended on their physique so to
help draw the money mine was all about
attitude but you know if I liked it but
I never ever posed in the ring just
because that wasn't my thing for more
Dan Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV stream for free
on BR live or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]